attention je me suis fait draguer par un
ministre moi je pense que c'est
christine kelly oui oui c'est sûr mais
en fait il n'était pas ministre encore
il est devenu après j'étais
présentatrice à lci à l'époque et à jour
ma mon ma boîte aux lettres on recevait
son courrier et tout les jours je voit
une carte postale louvre d'un politique
une lettre super enflammé bon quand tout
le monde connaissait évidemment mais
qu'ils étaient mariés donc au dessus du
bon ça mais c'est quand même un peu
choquant enfin ça passe non on ne peut
pas le chaînon pasaran on peut pas le
savoir
je veux le faire postale mais après je
rentre à la maison je montre à mon mari
qui est hacké furieux évidemment il m'a
laissée depuis en l'état
bref il était trop jaloux lci mais en
fait je regarde cette lettre mais de
lettres enflammées un truc de dingue
et puis après bon j'oublie des gens
passent etc et puis je vois traîner sur
la table des présentatrices une carte
comme la mienne du même du même
politique
oui les mêmes mots non mais en plus
non mais c'était en plus à y est
finalement il avait fait un tout les
présenter
alors après il est devenu ministre il ne
l'est plus aujourd'hui je rassure les
filles n'est plus ministre
c'est qui mais c'est mais j'ai été très
choqué de voir apparaître la lettre tue
c'est là dessus qu'il est juste de
droite que de gauche de gauche et c'est
pas dsk l'est mais c'était après avec
toutes les filles on a l'art et de
l'histoire